whether we like it or not politics has
now played a role in football two of
your players last night at the game
chose not to participate in the national
anthem how have you approached this
debate with the team you know it's
something I started my first year and
and you know it's obviously a subject
that you know that can be I don't want
it to be a divisive or or split our team
into and this the thing is is as our
team is very cohesive were one you know
sort of a one mind team and and I
understand that our players they honor
the flag and and and they honor the men
and women of the military and the Armed
Forces and and it's sometimes with these
players you know in guys like you know
Malcolm Jenkins who's been a tremendous
leader of our football team not only on
the field but but also off the field and
what he's done and in creating awareness
to a lot of a lot of social injustice is
that that you know that plague our
players our players are not immune to
the things that are going on in society
so it's obviously an ongoing debate with
the league and then the Players
Association and and it's still their
right to do that and it hasn't been a
situation that has divided our team
whatsoever